[Musique]
où
il
la vallée de l'okanagan connu pour ses
paysages ses vins ses fruits et sa
qualité de vie
[Musique]
mais depuis quelques années l'okanagan
est mieux connue pour ses extrêmes
climatiques
c'est un record absolu qui a été battu
hier il a fait plus de 46 degrés en
colombie britannique
on a un peu paniqué on a eu un peu peur
comment la vie allait réagir parce que
vraiment en 22 ans de carrière j'ai
jamais vu ça
des 6 3 7 6 c'est du jamais vu la
chaleur est arrivé très tôt et d'une
intensité qu'on avait jamais connu
la fréquence des événements extrêmes
augmente exactement ce que nos
projections climatiques nous disait mais
cela arrive un peu plus tôt privé
man et vos exploits
de nice mais aussi à étudier l'évolution
du climat en lien avec la gestion de
l'eau et le développement agricole
pendant des décennies dans la vallée de
l'okanagan
au cours des dix à quinze dernières
années nous avons enregistré plus de
journée au dessus de 30 et 35 degrés
celsius ce sont des conditions vraiment
stressante pour plusieurs cultures
[Musique]
la vallée de l'okanagan dispose d'un
climat semi aride et même désertique par
endroits surtout dans le sud près de la
frontière américaine en son centre il y
a le grand lac okanagan
long de 120 km cela qui donne
l'impression que la ressource en eau a
bondi 6 mais ce n'est pas le cas car ce
lac comme bien d'autres lacs au pays est
un vestige de la dernière grande
glaciation
[Musique]
l'eau qui alimente le lac est acheminée
depuis les montagnes environnantes par
un réseau de petites rivières
derrière moi vous pouvez voir le
ruisseau chat il s'agit du deuxième plus
importante affluents du lac okanagan il
est assez évident d'après sa taille que
notre approvisionnement en on est faible
[Musique]
environ 80% des précipitations de cette
région est perdu par évapotranspiration
dans l'écosystème donc à la fin de tout
ce site ce n'est qu' environ 7% de l'eau
qui est tombée sur la vallée qui coule
naturellement dans les rivières c'est
très peu il faut donc agir et très très
soigneusement
[Musique]
tout comme dans le sud de l'alberta la
vallée de l'okanagan compte sur un
important réseau d'irrigation pour
s'approvisionner en eau c'est en fait
l'un des plus vieux au pays
tous les utilisateurs d'eau de la vallée
que ce soit les villes les industries ou
les exploitations agricoles doivent
détenir un permis qui stipule la
quantité d'eau à louer
voici notre prise d'eau du ruisseau mais
sean nous prélevons environ 75 % du
débit pour la consommation humaine elle
reste retourne à l'écosystème
bob harras co gère l'un des districts
d'irrigation de la vallée ce district
abrite le plus importants affluents du
lac okanagan le ruisseau michonne situé
au sud de la ville de kelowna
non ce n'est pas très gros
durant les périodes de sécheresse
prolongées ce ruisseau se tarit presque
complètement en aval
l'eau de la rivière proviennent un
réservoir retenu par un barrage en amont
au printemps l'eau de la fonte des
neiges rempli le réservoir puis et
relâché durant la saison estivale
nous avons toujours rempli notre
réservoir
la capacité volume et donc là
le problème c'est que la demande en
hausse et accru depuis alors nous gruge
on nous réserve
et il y à beaucoup d'endroits dans la
vallée qui n'ont pas accès à des
réserves ce qui cause pas mal de stress
présente
le problème est le même qu'en alberta
l'eau dans la vallée de l'okanagan
dépend des précipitations de neige et
les changements climatiques provoquent
beaucoup de variations dans les
précipitations
[Musique]
prévisions de précipitations sont
imprécises dans les modèles de
changement climatique mais aussi qu'il
ya certaines amies ou les réservoirs ne
se rempliront pas il faudra alors
prendre des décisions des seychelles
if we lost et criques perdre pour deux
semaines au beau milieu de l'été notre
approvisionnement en hausse entraînerait
des pertes de l'ordre d'un demi milliard
pour la région
cela prouve à quel point ce ruisseau est
important pour l'économie ici et nous
n'avons pas d'autres sources
d'approvisionnement
devant l'urgence de la situation et
surtout avec les événements de l'été
2021 de nombreux agriculteurs et
vignerons mettent les bouchées doubles
pour réduire leur utilisation en eau
c'est le cas de la viticultrice séverine
peintes dans le sud de la vallée ici on
est dans un désert on a à peu près
entre 200 mm d'eau par an et 250 mm
d'eau par an ce qui a rien de tout et du
coup on a changé notre système
d'irrigation on est passé en
goutte-à-goutte donc c'est ce qu'on voit
ici
cette technique d'irrigation a pour
effet d'arroser lentement mais de façon
très ciblée à peu près 90% glos qui est
délivrée va actuellement dans le sol
l'équipe fait également des tests de
pression d'eau sur le feuillage ce
travail permet de voir comment les
plantes réagissent à l'apport en eau
donc on mesure la quantité d'eau à une
certaine pression qui va sortir donc dû
pétioles et ça nous permet de voir si
effectivement la plante est très stressé
et donc il faut donner le lot ou si
l'irrigation qu'on a fait pendant la
nuit ou la veille est encore en action
et la plante est modérément stressé du
coup comme on est capable de délivrer de
l'autre façon précise comme ça on a à
peu près diminué de 50 % la quantité
d'eau qu'on mettait au vignoble donc
c'est énorme
ces techniques de test de pression et
d'irrigation au goutte-à-goutte font des
petits partout chez les producteurs de
vins et de fruits de l'okanagan
comme dans les vergers de dv jean l'un
des plus importants producteurs de
cerises de la vallée
il ne fait aucun doute que nous aurons
besoin de plus d'eau dans l'avenir tout
en maintenant la quantité d'eau que nous
pouvons utiliser on pourra répondre à
cette demande si on utilise cette eau
avec parcimonie
depuis trois ans david jean met en
application une nouvelle technique
l'irrigation par déficit c'est à dire
diminuer considérablement l'apport en
eau après la récolte
nous terminons la récolte des cerises
entre la mi juillet et la feo et à
mesure que nous terminons dans un
secteur nous y réduisons de 40 à 50 %
l'utilisation tout
les faits et 12 on économise le et on
aide les arbres à se préparer pour
l'hiver
si vous réduisez la quantité d'eau que
vous fournissez à l'arbre la réponse de
larmes sera d'arrêter sa croissance
c'est comme si le fermer boutique pour
l'hiver c'est donc important s'il ya une
vague de froid précoce à la fin octobre
et en novembre vous voulez que les
arbres est déjà fait la transition
hivernal plutôt pour se protéger
cette privation d'eau est très utile
[Musique]
toutes ces techniques de conservation de
l'eau sont mises de l'avant non par
choix mais par obligation
car la vallée de l'okanagan vite une
croissance de sa population des demandes
du maine et son agriculture
le problème c'est que l'offre en eau
elle n'est pas en croissance
de nombreux cours d'eau dans le canadian
sont entièrement dédiés à la
consommation humaine cet aménagement
s'est fait à une époque où on ne tenait
pas compte des écosystèmes mais cela a
changé et le problème ne cesse de
s'aggraver
cela devient une question sociale ou
politique la science fourni certaines
réponses mais les décisions finales
appartiennent du site
web voulons-nous une vallée de
production alimentaire ou de
développement résidentiel
voulons-nous le statu quo mais tout en
sachant que ça ne pourra pas durer car
les grandes chaleurs que nous avons vécu
ici cette année vont se reproduire
et
si nous ne pouvons pas gérer notre ou
adéquatement je ne sais pas comment les
gens ailleurs au pays pourront le faire
si nous parvenons à partager la
ressource équitablement alors vous savez
je pense que nous serons un modèle pour
le reste du pays
[Musique]